herzlich willkommen und her sehr geehrte
damen und herren liebe frau burtscher
meine herren professoren nach gut vier
wochen mitte märz wo wir in der dynamik
entschieden haben bund und länder auch
zu größeren einschränkenden maßnahmen
für das öffentliche leben zu kommen ist
es auch aus sicht der gesundheitspolitik
zeit eine erste zwischenbilanz zu ziehen
wir ändern uns mit dem märz haben wir
eine sehr starke dynamik bekommen
im ausbruchsgeschehen hier in
deutschland getriggert auch durch die
zahlreichen winter urlaubsrückkehrer wo
sich im nachhinein herausgestellt hat
dass insbesondere in den bekannten ski
und winter urlaubsregionen das virus
sich sehr stark verbreiten konnte ohne
dass die betroffenen das wussten und
anschließend ja auch in ganz europa sich
dann getragen hat auch durch volksfeste
gab es entsprechendes ausbruchsgeschehen
regional die verdoppelung zeit hat sich
immer weiter verkürzt für die zahl der
infizierten und deswegen haben wir uns
ja bund und länder gemeinsam zu einer
vollbremsung entschieden auch durch die
maßnahmen die ergriffen wurden die
absage von großveranstaltungen die
schließung von kitas und schulen im
öffentlichen leben cafés restaurants
viele viele andere maßnahmen
nun können wir sagen dass war
erfolgreich wir haben es geschafft das
dynamische wachstum zurückzubringen zu
einem linearen wachstum die
infektionszahlen sind deutlich gesunken
vor allem auch die relative steigerung
von tag zu tag der ausbruch ist stand
heute wieder beherrschbaren
beherrschbarer geworden
ich finde eine sehr wichtigen der
wichtige ermutigende zahl ist auch die
das seit dem zwölften vierten täglich
mehr menschen genesen
als wir neu infizierte haben wir haben
im moment über 80.000 genesene von gut
130 tausend die sich bisher nach den
zahlen des robert-koch-instituts
infiziert haben und das ist aus meiner
sicht ganz besonders wichtig für diese
erste ausbruchs dynamik und dem was sich
daraus ergeben hat war das
gesundheitssystem
keiner zeit bis hierhin überfordert bei
der bewältigung der krone epidemie
schneidet deutschland im internationalen
vergleich gut ab
das macht uns demütig aber nicht
übermütig das ist ganz ganz wichtig
insofern begrüße ich es dass sich die
ministerpräsidenten und die
bundeskanzlerin entschieden haben die
bestehenden auflagen nur vorsichtig und
schrittweise zu lockern
viele meiner internationalen kolleginnen
und kollegen fragen mich derzeit wie
deutschland das macht um bei uns auch
noch so viele intensivbetten zum
beispiel frei sind und das hat eine
ganze reihe von gründen aus meiner sicht
ich will 23 nennen zum einen ist trotz
aller kritik und allen
unzulänglichkeiten im alltag das
deutsche gesundheitssystem insgesamt in
einer guten verfassung gut ausgestattet
was fachkräfte die hohe zahl an
fachkräften angeht ärztinnen und ärzte
pflegekräfte apothekerinnen und
apotheker alle gesundheitsberufe
wir haben zudem ein sehr engmaschiges
netz auch von niedergelassenen haus- und
fachärzten die auch mithelfen jetzt als
erster schutzwall in dieser chronik dem
i was wichtig ist zu sehen ist dass
sechs von sieben cupid platzieren
sechs von sieben ambulant behandelt und
begleitet werden können weil sie vor
allem milde und milde verläufe haben mit
geringer symptomatik das heißt also die
krankenhäuser können sich konzentrieren
auf die schweren verläufe und dieses
zusammenspiel von ambulant und stationär
ist eben auch einer der großen vorteile
in unserem system und das bringt mich zu
der stationären versorgung wir haben
exzellente kliniken
wir haben kliniken die den aufruf den es
mitte märz gegeben hat den wir dann ja
auch gesetzlich unterlegt haben
planbare operationen und aufnahmen zu
verschieben
genutzt haben um intensivbetten
tatsächlich auch frei zu machen und
gleichzeitig auch zusätzliche intensiv
kapazitäten aufzubauen so dass es
gelungen ist die zahl der intensivbetten
in deutschland bis hierhin richtung
40.000 bereits zu erhöhen was im
internationalen vergleich für ein
mit unserer größe mit unserer
bevölkerungszahlen eine sehr gute zahl
ist und wir haben die zeit auch genutzt
und dazu werden ein professor bruch und
der professor zugleich was sagen
beim thema medikamentenstudien und
impfstoff die begleitung entsprechende
entwicklung tatsächlich auch aktiv zu
sein
zu drei bereichen möchte ich kurz was
sagen zum einen werden wir die große
zahl an freien betten 10.000 freie
intensivbetten natürlich nicht auf dauer
so in dem umfang vorhalten können und
müssen deswegen verstehe ich auch die
forderungen die es in den letzten tagen
mehr gegeben hat danach auch die zahl
der operationen wieder hochzufahren weil
natürlich für jemanden dem vor vier
wochen gesagt wurde der eigentlichen
termin hatte einen operationstermin ein
termin für den eingriff für eine
hüftoperation eine rückenoperation einer
tumor operation möglicherweise diese
ungewissheit wann findet denn jetzt
diese operation statt
ohne frage eine seelische belastung ist
zusätzlich zu der körperlichen belastung
die da ist und deswegen müssen wir
darüber reden wie wir es schaffen können
so wie wir es auch im alltagsleben ihr
schaffen müssen zu einer neuen
normalität zu kommen mit dem virus zu
leben auch dort zu einem neuen einer
neuen normalität im krankenhausbetrieb
zu kommen und wir sollten das genau so
schrittweise mit der nötigen vorsicht
machen wie wir es in anderen bereichen
auch machen mit blick auf die
krankenhäuser das ist eine sehr sehr
schwierige balance
aber natürlich müssen wir beiden gerecht
werden der versorgung der patientinnen
und patienten die sozusagen im
normalbetrieb natürlich ihre versorgung
brauchen und zwar die notfälle
schlaganfälle herzinfarkte richtigen
kliniken dass die zahl zum beispiel der
herzinfarkte die eingeliefert werden
deutlich gesunken ist sie sich fragen wo
die sozusagen sind was da passiert
darüber muss man natürlich reden und
gleichzeitig eben die nötige kapazität
vorzuhalten
aber auch für alle entwicklungen im
rahmen von krone und cupid erkrankung
dabei hilft uns sehr das register dass
wir nach und nach hier aufgebaut haben
zusammen mit der intensivmedizin und den
krankenhäusern seit donnerstag ist
dieses register
die zulieferung zum register auch
verpflichtend für die krankenhäuser und
wir wollen dieses register auch zusammen
mit den krankenhäusern und den
intensivmediziner und dem robert koch
institut weiter ausbauen so dass es
besser gelingen kann noch besser
gelingen kann auch auf klinik gezogen
und auf regionen bezogen daraus
vorhersagen abzuleiten so dass wir dann
ab mai denke ich schrittweise eben auch
eine neue normalität im klinikbetrieb
kommen können bei denen wir eine
bestimmte zahl der intensivbetten und
der betten in den krankenhäusern
weiterhin vorhalten für tobit 19
behandlungen denkt wir starten mit einer
größenordnung von 25 bis 30 prozent um
dann eben schritt für schritt immer
genauer auch in der steuerung zu werden
immer nach dem prinzip der vorsorge und
der vorsicht zweiter kurz zudem testen
wir haben über 1,7 millionen corona
tests bisher in deutschland gemacht das
sind inzwischen und 350.000 in der woche
wir haben eine theoretische kapazität in
den laboren von bis zu 700.000 pro woche
wenn die entsprechenden reagenzien auch
da sind aber auch dort hat sich die lage
und wir arbeiten jeden tag daran
schrittweise verbessert ich verstehe
deswegen manche kritik an den tests die
ich in den letzten tagen gelesen habe
auch nur bedingt flächendeckende tests
machen ganz pauschal auch wenig sinn
weil natürlich nach dem test schon
innerhalb nach einer halben stunde
derjenige der gerade getestet wurde
schon wieder infiziert sein kann das ist
ja immer nur eine momentaufnahme
und deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir
zielgerichtet testen auch nach den
empfehlungen des robert-koch-instituts
insbesondere natürlich verdachtsfälle
patienten mit symptomen und deren
kontaktpersonen dass wir aber und das
hat auch schon begonnen in den letzten
ein zwei wochen noch zielgerichteter mit
blick auf pflegeeinrichtungen und das
gesundheitswesen selbst testen etwa bei
der verlegung von patienten und
pflegebedürftigen zwischen krankenhaus
in pflegeeinrichtungen bei der
neuaufnahme von pflegebedürftigen oder
auch medizinisches personal und dann
dritte so letztes thema das ich
ansprechen möchte eingangs ist die frage
der masken und der beschaffung der
schutzausrüstung für die pflegekräfte
und die ärztinnen und ärzte
medizinische schutzmasken sind sehr sehr
wichtig für diejenigen die jeden tag für
uns an der front gegen das kroner virus
kämpfen
doch dort sind wir nach anfänglichen
schwierigkeiten mittlerweile in einer
besseren lage seit mitte märz haben wir
uns als bundesministerium für gesundheit
direkt eingeschaltet in die beschaffung
allein diese woche sind mittlerweile 80
millionen masken durch die
bundesbeschaffung nach deutschland
gebracht worden davon 20 millionen ffp
zwei masken und diese befinden sich über
die woche und auch in diesen tagen und
auch heute in der verteilung
wir haben zusammen in zusammenarbeit mit
internationalen konzernen deutschen
konzernen die asiengeschäft haben dort
auch eben es geschafft bessere
längerlaufende verbindungen aufzubauen
sodass wir auch nicht auf den
zwischenhandel in dem umfang mehr
angewiesen sind wie vorher und zudem das
freut mich besonders konnten wir in
dieser woche zuschläge geben für
produzenten hier in deutschland sie
wissen dass wir eine erste ausschreibung
als bundesministerium für gesundheit
gemacht haben für den aufbau von
produktionskapazitäten für medizinische
schutzmasken hier in deutschland
sie konnten die zuschläge geben an gut
50 unternehmen die ab mitte august pro
woche zehn millionen ft2 masken und 40
millionen op masken herstellen wollen
und werden dafür haben sie den zuschlag
erhalten und auch ich denke auch das ist
wichtig weil mit dieser größenordnung
wird tatsächlich den bedarf für das
gesundheitswesen den wir haben im großen
und ganzen als basis bedarf dann auch
decken könnten und für eine epidemie bei
der wir nicht wissen wie lange sie uns
auch noch beschäftigen wird ist denke
ich diese unabhängigkeit sehr sehr
wichtig abschließend möchte ich danke
sagen
den bürgerinnen und bürgern die
mitgeholfen haben mitgemacht haben mit
einer sehr hohen akzeptanz bis hierhin
und auch darüber hinaus schlicht und
ergreifend indem sie persönliche
kontakte verzichtet haben was sicherlich
auch über die ostertage nicht leicht
gefallen ist ja mitgeholfen dass das
gesundheitssystem nicht überlastet wird
unsere aktion hashtag wir bleiben zu
hause zum beispiel des
bundesministeriums für gesundheit
hat auch sehr gute unterstützung dabei
bekommen und auch mithelfen können ich
möchte danke sagen allen die nicht von
zu hause aus arbeiten können und jeden
tag mithelfen dass unsere versorgung
gesichert ist ärztinnen und ärzte
pflegekräfte alle die im
gesundheitswesen tätig sind im
einzelhandel verkäuferinnen und
verkäufer für unsere sicherheit viele
viele andere mehr
die unsere wertschätzung verdienen aber
natürlich auch unsere anerkennung
darüber hinaus auch darüber im übrigen
für die pflege sind wir in konkreten
gesprächen
ich möchte auch denen danke sagen die
ungeduldig sind gerade auf dem weg
zurück in eine neue normalität
ich verstehe ist dass diejenigen die
auch von der wirtschaftlichen existenz
frage bestehen natürlich fragen danach
haben wie es denn jetzt weiter geht
in den nächsten schritten und wann sie
auch wieder sich wirtschaftlich
betätigen können und ich verstehe gut
aus dem eigenen persönlichen umfeld wie
auch etwa eltern mit kleineren kindern
die zum beispiel selbst berufstätig sind
bei der frage wie schaut es mit kita wie
schaut es mit grundschule wie schaut es
mit betreuung für die kinder aus auch
fragen haben weil sie natürlich jeden
tag stress und doppelbelastung erleben
und deswegen ist es wichtig und die
familienministerin hat das ja auch
angekündigt dass wir insbesondere für
berufstätige eltern eine lösung finden
wir wollen schrittweise die richtige
balance finden für den schutz der
gesundheit das öffentliche leben und
unsere wirtschaft wir wollen
schrittweise den weg finden eine neue
normalität wir müssen lernen mit dem
virus zu leben jede einzelne und auch
wir als gesellschaft wir haben stand
heute gute chancen gut durch diese zeit
der epidemie zu kommen als gesellschaft
als nation und auch mit unserem
gesundheitswesen und wir werden jeden
tag weiter daran arbeiten dass das auch
gelingt